when the economics goes bad we become
vulnerable to bad ideas hey I'm your
friendly neighborhood Dave Rubin with a
quick reminder to subscribe to our
channel and click the belt to get
notified of our videos and joining me
today is an international best-selling
author and journalist so his greatest
claim to fame is now being a three-time
returning Rubin report guest Douglas
Murray welcome back to the Rubin report
very good to be with you again Dave who
else has managed three times who else
has been three times I believe Ben
Shapiro Jordan Peterson dad said this is
yeah this is this is the a-team maybe
maybe sam harris snuck in there I'm not
sure anyway it is good to have you on my
friend I wish we were doing this in
person but you were across the pond how
is life across the pond these days well
you know it's it's it's alright we have
our own forms of madness going on here
as you do in America but broadly
speaking we're still standing despite
all of the politicians best efforts
alright now I want to get into this book
because I've read about half of it so
far and as you know I just wrote my
first book and I was reading this going
man I wish I was a better author because
you my friend have a way with words so
I've got the book right here and I
always noticed that on cable news when
people are gonna read something they put
on glasses I don't wear glasses
these are prop glasses but I thought I'd
put them on so that I look a little
smarter as I read this because on the
inside flap you have something here that
I thought just summed up almost every
reason that I do this show and talk
about these issues and and love what you
do it says we're living through a
postmodern era in which the grand
narratives of religion and political
ideology of collapse in their place have
emerged a crusading desire to write
perceived wrongs and a weaponization of
identity both accelerated by the new
forms of social and news media narrow
sets of interests now dominate the
agenda as society becomes more and more
tribal and as Murray shows the
casualties are mounting now I'm going to
slowly take off my glasses
how was that that was pretty good right
I'm like a believ of like Anderson
Cooper no that that little synopsis
right there I think is exactly what's on
everyone's mind these days that a small
few have somehow taken over all of the
narratives so I guess my first question
would be when when do you think this all
started
I think it's a phenomenon of the last
decade I think that it starts in earnest
after the financial crash of 2008 you
know we when we look back at history
causes of revolutions and so on we know
that when the economics goes bad other
things happen and I think that we
pretend at the moment as if the crash
sort of didn't happen or didn't have an
effect in our culture and of course it
didn't cause something like that's going
to and I say in the introduction to the
madness of crowds you know it's not a
surprise that young people who can't
accumulate capital capital in their
lives don't have any particular love of
capitalism and it's not surprising that
a generation that finds it incredibly
hard to get on the property ladder for
instance is going to be susceptible to
ideologies that claim to be able to
solve every inequity on earth so my view
is that that when the economics goes bad
we become vulnerable to bad ideas and
the ones I write about in the madness of
crowds
I think these ideas have been gestating
since at least the 1980s these things
that we now know is identity politics
intersectionality possibly the ugliest
word in the language and and these has
been these have been hanging around
since about the 80s but they only come
flooding in in the last decade and then
in the last five years as you can prove
I lay out some of it in the book in the
last five years that's when all this
stuff actually became weaponized yeah
and when it started to be used as a real
bath ring wrap all right so first off
thank you for actually saying the title
of the book that was very unprofessional
to me it is called the madness of crowds
you are correct right there so that's it
that's an interesting theory that you've
laid out that basically these ideas
these sort of bad ideas and and
totalitarian ideas that they've been
sitting there but it takes something
else in this case an economic crash to
bring them up to the fold so you think
if the crash had not happened you think
that basically would have been a buffer
to just kind of keep these ideas under
our normal layer of discourse well I
think so I mean the
you know it's it's been on my mind for
many years as I've noticed this sort of
intrusion into the public space of these
ideas and of these weaponized identity
groupings people being used against each
other you know gay people seeming to be
used for something to hit straight
people and people of different races
being used against each other and women
being used against men you know this
sort of this horrible thing we've been
through in recent years so many times
and yeah when I started looking into the
intellectual origins of some of this I
sort of assumed that there were serious
texts and that these these these these
ideas came from a serious place and I
was sort of stunned when I started
looking into it that really it's it's a
lot of assertions that are being made in
these texts you know there's a famous
foundational text of intersectionality
called unpacking the knapsack packing
the invisible map second I sort of
thought this by Professor Wellesley I
sort of thought well well this must be
some kind of serious you know attempt at
some mm I might be wrong but no it's not
it's a few pages of assertions and that
started to make me particularly
interested so I thought well how did how
did a few assertions by one Wells the
academic become a sort of one of the
basis for something that is now being
tried out everywhere and and the real
shock to me as I was researching this
book was this isn't just you know it
broke out from these so liberal arts
colleges like you know Wellesley and a
few sort of places like Berkeley and
Judith Barlow and this sort of stuff it
broke out from there but we now see it
being flooding through among other
things the corporate world and that was
a huge I mean I'm just amazed that the
extent to which is has gone through that
now and you know this but but the only
people who don't think that this stuff
is coming towards them are people who
are basically self-employed and don't
have much connection with other people
in an office or anything but everybody
else knows that through human resources
departments commitments to diversity all
of this sort of thing and this is all
coming for them and I'm just I'm just
amazed as I say that a set of ideas
which is we'll come on to it
provably wrong are provably not gonna
work and contradictory
self-contradictory it's just amazing to
me that this should have flooded through
governments corporations as if it's
something that might work when it can't
when you were doing the research for the
book and you found some of these
documents which as they're talking about
the genesis of intersectionality it's a
couple pages basically in a weird way
would you have preferred to have found a
solid foundation to argue against you
know something that even if you
disagreed with all of the outcomes that
you would have been able to fight in
sort of like an even way as opposed to
fighting something that because it's not
foundational you're just kind of
fighting all over the place right that's
what I assumed I thought I thought this
is gonna require some you know serious
delving and so on and I I just say I was
amazed at this but what's more I mean I
mean you know the academia bit in a way
is is the most tedious part of it for
obvious reasons because once it breaks
into the pop culture world for instance
you know then it then it became we
talked about mass mass entertainment and
and indeed I think mass derangement when
some of these ideas go into the pop
cultural world well but but but these
are these claims made the foundational
claims are among other things written in
the type of academic jargon that is so
bad that it's clear that it is prose
intended only to do one of two things
the first is to hide a meaning because
there isn't one and the second one is to
write this badly because the author
knows that what they're saying isn't
true and they're trying to cover over
the fact but I mean I mean I give
examples and I did the audio book for
this book and I mean just reading some
of them out aloud I mean like I kept
corpsing in the sound booth because I
mean they are such ridiculously badly
written texts and and as I say I mean I
give examples but this this is a real
this is fraudulence on a massive scale
okay well here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna dive into it and there one
of the beauties of the book actually is
the way you lay it out is
such simplicity and in fact you really
only have four chapters here which then
you have some interludes for but it's
really four main ideas but I'm going to
put my fake glasses on for just one more
moment here because I want to read the
two quotes at the beginning of the book
because I feel you've you started us off
beautifully here you said it's this is a
quote the special mark of the modern
world is not that it is skeptical but
that it is dogmatic without knowing it
that's G K Chesterton and then uh this
next one oh my gosh look at her butt oh
my gosh look at her butt oh my gosh look
at her butt look at her butt look at it
look at it look at it look at her butt
by Nicki Minaj and Minaj and my gosh
Douglass why those two quotes and now
I'm putting the glasses away my friend
yeah that's that's the epigraph page I I
sort of thought it did signaled what I
was planning to do my hope I have done
in the book which is in part to just
show people what's going on I go into in
the chapter in women I I go into the
issue of miss Minaj
but yeah well let's hold that for a
second yeah the GK Chesterton quote it
seems to me incredibly opposite to the
point I'm trying to make you know that
that we have an extraordinary set of
dogmas in our time whereas dogmatic as
any age but it requires I think you know
somebody to step back and say what are
the dogmas and I just have decided that
it was worth putting them down the four
that I see most closely gay which is the
first chapter women the second the third
is race and the fourth is trans and we
we basically if I could sum up what I'm
trying to do with this and not show it's
that I think we are pretending to know
about things we don't know about
and we're pretending not to know about
things we all knew till yesterday and
this these two things simultaneously are
one of the reasons why our societies are
dementing ourselves we pretend to be
exceptionally sure about things like
trans for instance when we really don't
know very much at all about it I lay out
you know I lay out the most plausible
decent reasonable case for saying what
in what in this claim these rights
claims is is legitimate and there's
something new to think about and what is
it that's just dementing so that's an
example of something we pretend to be
really sure about and we just don't know
almost anything about yeah and then
there are things that we really do know
a lot about or used to know a lot about
- yes they like relations between the
sexes which we pretend like total
mysteries to us so okay so I love that
that as I said four chapters and it's
it's just so simple it's gay women what
and trans Gate race and trans thank you
okay so let's just start gay that's the
title that's it no cheeky titles no
nothing just gay three letters so I
think most people watching this want gay
people to live equally under the law and
that is the way it is and pretty much
every Western society but what you talk
about here is that's not really what the
gay movement is sort of about anymore
correct yeah I mean I think that in each
of these cases there's an argument that
what we're going through is a kind of
over correction in some way I would
suggest that there's always been a
problem in every rights movement of
knowing when you've got to equal and
when some people have overshot so my
view is that a lot of people don't like
equal actually they want to go to better
this is really painful staff but the
extent to which being gay can be
presented as if it's actually a bit
better than being straight being being
black is not just about being equal it's
it's a bit better than being white and I
get into that in the race chapter you
know and and and and the example with
women is you know that the what
christine lagarde the head of the IMF
did you know that women she says the
financial
crass crash at Lehman Brothers might not
have happened if it had been lame and
sisters as if women are absolutely equal
to men and also a bit better but I think
this is a very dangerous overcorrection
in the right swing and we've gave it's
it's got a lot of a lot of unpleasant
connotations which I go into in the book
which I think were there a night race
where they were from the beginning of
the gay rights movement and I
particularly I go into one thing which I
don't think anyone's written about
before which is what I described is the
divide between gay and queer and I say
that gay is just you know people who are
attracted to members of their own sex
like both you and I happen to be we're
somewhat over-represented in this
conversation it's very it's very
heteronormative our conversations you
see being gay is is not very interesting
beyond that but there's there's a
there's a divide that was always there
within the gay rights movement which was
between people who are gay and people
who are queer and queer as ice as I
describe it is people who think that
being attracted to a member of their own
sex it is merely the first stage but a
bigger campaign such as for instance
bringing down the society or or or
queering the society or bringing down
capitalism or or some of those and and
I'm amazed that this hasn't been sort of
focused on before because actually a lot
of the pain that has come from parts of
the gay rights movement over the years
has been precisely the people who didn't
do gay they were doing clear they were
using gay as merely the first thing to
do a bigger political project and that's
common in each of these chapters there's
each of them there is a group trying to
do something like that so then what do
we call the gays who are not trying to
destroy Western civilization and the
patriarchy the gays like us or we're
just day that's it that's so boring is
that did you come up with a better word
come on no I'm sticking with gay on this
one but but it's it's a very important
thing to identify it was always there
it was there Stonewall onwards it was
there before indeed that and it's been
in in recent years that something very
interesting does happen
with the remaining bit of the gay rights
sort of groups which is that they they
have become vulnerable to what I
described as Georgian retirement
syndrome you know that's in Georgia
after slaying the dragon and getting the
acclaim of slaying the dragon staggers
around the land looking for ever more
dragons to slay and can't find them or
find smaller and smaller beasts and
eventually may be found swinging his
sword at Finnair and with via with
remainders of Finn since the gay press
this is what they're doing they wish
they'd been at Stonewall they wish that
they'd been fighting back in the day
some of them did but they they get
addicted to the the barricade manner and
that's why we have this very strange
thing and I I really I go straight for
them on this why it's turned out the
fences the gay press that remains is
basically a sort of weird social justice
warrior campaigning things so so much so
that just this past week when my book
came out the main gay magazines in
America and Britain attacked me for
misgendering Sam Smith the pop singer
who came out as non-binary and I said I
don't my viewers which is I don't think
as any such thing as non-binary I think
it's to say I think it's it's just
absolutely impossible to determine what
the difference is between saying you're
non-binary and just shouting look at me
and I think that's what he did and I
said so and I said I'm not doing they
then I'm not doing all this all this
crap and both both sides of the Atlantic
the gay the remit legacy gay press said
you know right-wing maniac Marie
you know outrageously misgender Sam
Smith on radio show all making sure they
didn't mention that I myself am gay and
and the best part was well the best part
of the whole thing forget that they
don't mention you're gay right because
they want to take away you're a gay card
but that the unless this happened more
than once I saw the video clip of the
radio show that you were doing and the
woman you were arguing against or having
the conversation with she kept saying
that you have to use his proper pronouns
so in it in her own sentence she was
misgendering him yes she accuse me of
bullying
him for not using his correct pronouns
because of course I'm in a great
position to bully a multimillion-pound
earning popstar anyhow not bullying they
that's right now this woke stuff is
harder than it looks
[Laughter]
as I say this is an example of it the
basically the legacy gay press doesn't
have much to do other than attack gays
who it thinks are are letting the side
down by not being woken up for social
justice warrior enough and I just have
boundless contempt for these people
there's a couple other interesting
things that have happened through an
American lens on this did you happen to
see that right now Peabody jej who is
openly gay is starting to feel the wrath
of exactly what you're talking about
because I've seen now the queer
magazines or whatever it is say he's
just a heteronormative man who doesn't
identify with being queer he happens to
be married to a man he has sex with a
man I assume but that's not good enough
even for him who's basically a
progressive they still want the him to
live under the booth that's right well
there's there's a given example in each
chapter of where we see the naked ly
political nature of these movements now
the example of another example before
this week one that I give in the book is
Peter Thiel yeah can Valley a tech
entrepreneur billionaire who is
denounced by Advocate magazine States
legacy gay magazine is denounced by
advocate after he comes out for Trump in
2016 an advocate says Peter Thiel may
sleep with men but in no way is he gay
so like we've all been doing it wrong
all these years and there's something
else you're meant to be doing anyhow but
but but but this happens on each of
these you know when Kanye West comes out
for Trump
he's denounced in the Atlantic is no
longer being black and Germaine Greer
when she doesn't do the trans one in the
right order is denounced there's no
longer a feminist and you know if gay
men aren't gay and and Germaine Greer
isn't a feminist and and Kanye West
isn't black
what are we really talking about with
these characteristics and I think what
we're talking about is a naked political
push youth disgracefully using identity
issues and people's identity as a way to
carry out and batter a political project
do you think that there when it comes to
sexuality there's a particularly
perverse version of this which is last
time I had you in studio the last thing
that I asked you about was was that
because you're gay does it make you more
sensitive perhaps to some of these
movements do we do gay people do we kind
of see things a little bit earlier
because we are the other that sort of
thing and you basically said yes your
skin might be a little bit thinner when
it comes to all of these issues because
as an other you identify with the other
so in a weird way the social justice
movement can really use gays and
minorities in a really effective way
because it makes it all about them it's
so it's so it's so twisted yeah if
there's certainly some of that going on
but I must say I mean there are several
groups you could sort of identify
pushing some of these identity issues
and I think there are these people who
who genuinely are just using this as
politics you know that it's really
identifiable now I think there are
though I mean that we should credit it
there are a lot of young people in their
teens and twenties who who have actually
absorbed this worldview who do actually
believe that we live in a uniquely you
know dangerous time as opposed to being
the most fortunate people in history
ever anywhere and who actually have
imbibed these these ideas that you know
we live in this on the verge of fascism
sort of state and you have very little
context with history and all sorts of
thing and I I really one of the one of
the aims of this book is it it's written
for those people and I really hope they
read it to try to get them out of that
and just suggest a more reasonable view
of the situation we're in you know
because my experience in recent years I
think I say this in the introduction is
that on all of these issues
of LGBT issues race issues and women's
issues basically my experience in recent
years has been it's been like watching a
train finally pulling in to its desired
destination only at the very moment of
pulling into the station to suddenly get
a head of steam and go shooting off down
the tracks and off the tracks and
scattering people in their wake and it's
almost like at the moment of victory a
load of people decided that victory
wasn't enough mm-hmm
we see that we see that all over those I
mean I think Sweden is probably the best
example of that where they've had this
great egalitarian society where men and
women are so obviously equal and yet the
social justice warriors are now trying
to re-engineer society so that there'll
be as many women engineers but we know
that women just aren't as interested in
that that's not sexist it just right I
mean listen this stuff is dementing
because we're trying to run a set of
programs that can't be run
simultaneously and are not going to work
and you know I mean we can both wax
eloquent about that about the number of
contradictions for instance in these
movements that's going on at the moment
and I mean the most striking one to me
is is what I describe as the
hardware/software issue where do it take
us there I think I am I owe this or
insight from conversations with our
mutual friend Eric Weinstein but the the
the way I see it is that every rights
movement in the late 20th century
discovered that the best way to get
sympathy for your case was to say that
you had a hardware issue so gay uh
argues that argues against a lifestyle
choice by saying no born this way move
from lifestyle choice to Lady Gaga and
you see I actually say I mean I'm
definitely chucked out of the church of
gay for saying this but I actually say
and I wrote this before the most recent
study emerged in science magazine it was
a largest study of gay men and women to
have come out so far I actually say what
that study did conclude which is that
it's it's almost certainly got a signal
I couldn't hardware component but
there's also a nurturer rearing issue
that there there are lots of things that
are slightly buck that the the settled
place that we fought or at least a lot
of gay rights campaigners got to but it
was understandable to do a hardware
rather than software because it
countered that you know that they're
sort of religious bigotry among others
that did you know lifestyle choice and
but the problem about this is that other
movements learned from that the trans
movement in particular learning that and
in recent years in super fast time has
been trying to say absolutely nothing to
do with software this is a hardware
issue trans people are born trans and as
I say we actually don't know very much
about it but here's here's a dementing
thing if I may make the point which is
that um we are pretending at the moment
in our societies that gay is Hardware
trans is hardware but being a woman is
software now that is dementing right so
you can pick your you can somehow pick
your gender which we know is a physical
reality but you can't pick your
sexuality which science has proven
there's at least a conversation to have
there right so chromosomes are of no
significance but how you feel is the
most important thing we're trying to
make hardware software and software
hardware and you know it doesn't say
there's no wonder the this this or the
casualty list the feminists has kept
growing because there's a very noble
given a roll call of of them in chapter
and the book there is no wonder that a
group of feminists kept coming across
this tripwire because it's incredibly
insulting for a lot of women to be told
you know as Judith Butler and others it
had started off the sort of theoretical
stuff and others have picked it up and
weaponized it but you know being a woman
is a matter of performativity you know
and as I say you you can't run these two
programs simultaneously but we've been
trying and I think that's one of the
absolute basis for a dementing manner so
I want to do a little more on trans at
the end but we'll go in order of the
chapters that you did but can you just
explain I thought it was really
interesting that you separated the gay
and
chapters because you know it is LGBTQ
and I always tell people that me as the
G in this case I have no more insight
into what a trans person's life is like
than a straight male would or lesbian
would or anything else these are these
are very different things but we've
lumped these letters together but why
did you intentionally separate it for
the purposes of the book well I think
they are separate things and I say at
one point in the gauge apt you know that
the G's don't have very much in common
at all with the ELLs I may never meet
particularly soaking those spaces oh
geez and ELLs don't don't really have
much in common
the G's and the ELLs are very suspicious
of the bees and the bees and the bees
don't have anything really in common
with the t's and and they're all stuck
in this you know dave chappelle rather
just a week before my book came out did
this at a rather large audience on his
Netflix show you know that so in the
same car but they're very different
destinations and the thing with the the
thing with a t1 that is so interesting
which I know the same I really been
delving into this is speaking to a lot
of people and interviewing people and
you know really trying to work out as I
say what's actually going on here and
and one of the things I think that's
most striking about it and why finish on
trans is that it's obvious why trans
runs against women I mean I'm sorry I
should take by the way I should say the
fascinating thing about this is of
course the intersection lists and social
justice warriors all pretend these are
like interlocking oppressions and that
if you if you undo one you will undo the
others or you know that you'll create
this sort of harmony because women's
issues and gay issues and racial issues
are all the same thing now the point I'm
trying to make here is that they are
exactly wrong because each of these
issues actually runs against the other
so as I say it's obvious why tea runs
against women because it among other
things it does things and makes claims
about what women are that are highly
insulting to a lot of women not all but
an awful lot and then you have the run
against gay that trans presents and I
just I think this is I think this is an
absolutely fascinating
corner that hasn't been gone into enough
which is that you know as we know now
from studies young people diagnosed with
so-called gender dysphoria the the stud
what studies we have show that around
eighty to eighty-five percent of the of
the kids diagnosed with that are going
to grow out of it and are likely to
become gay men or gay women and we all
know this from our own experience and I
think that there has been a totally
submerged conversation in recent years
which has only happened in private and
wondered by the way one the nicest
things about this book starting to be
read is the number of people who say to
me Douglas this is the conversation my
wife and I have over dinner and we say
we cannot talk about this outside of
this house and so on so I say my
self-appointed role is to say aloud all
of the things that everyone else
whispers but I I know that this
conversation had been going on in among
gay people in particular which is am I
totally sure that my you know sort of
tomboy friend wouldn't have been
diagnosed as actually gender dysphoria
am I sure that my you know male friend
who is a kind of camp you know teenager
wouldn't and if it had been now have
been told actually you're not gonna grow
up to be a happy healthy gay man you're
gonna grow up to be a woman and we've
decided you're actually a woman and that
is that is that is that hits of the
absolute root of a lot of gay men and a
lot of gay women and we've just passed
it over as if it's all part of the same
happy rainbow coalition it isn't it
totally destroys the other bits of the
coalition so all right so let's let's
just continue with the trans part then
since we're in the thick of it right now
do you think there's also something
bizarre about the amount of energy that
the topic trans has we're so gay rights
you know you can very easily start you
know you can go from Stonewall you can
look over the course of a few decades
where there were some wins then it
happened in America at least through
states rights and then eventually the
Supreme Court and a cultural awareness
and all that and then it was almost as
if the
second gay marriage happened everyone
was kind of like this and then trans
which wasn't really being talked about
and you can argue maybe we should have
paid more attention to it culturally or
whatever but that it suddenly became
like v8 thing and the second it became
the iya thing you couldn't take any
counter argument whatsoever yeah
Time magazine puts it on the cover in
2015 trans the next the next rights
battle see again there are people for
whom life is given meaning by having an
endless set of rights battles and once
you've done gay you got to do trans and
once you dump trans you've got to get
onto non-binary or whatever you've made
up today and so on and and I think that
this is people should be intensely
suspicious about people who see who
tried to get meaning in their lives from
this some Georgian retirement issue for
and and yeah III I lay out why I think
trans happened where it did and when it
did but here's the thing why trans I
think is so interesting and why finish
on it is because in some ways it's the
one that's betrayed itself most in
recent years it's shown something
clearest in recent years I think Eric on
your show once made this point as well
that that you can learn an awful lot by
seeing the steps which rights movements
take and the order they take them in the
gay rights movement didn't start with
gay marriage and gay adoption and gay
parenting and surrogates and so on it
started with basic rights quite
understandably rightly and it makes all
the way along to this bit now that's
because in incremental steps are gonna
be necessary to build a coalition so one
of the things that's become clear with
trans in recent years is that they
skipped all of the sensible intermediary
steps and what I mean by that is for
instance they skipped the intersex one
people born with a you know unclear
genitalia this is a really awkward
subject is it's not very common but it's
definitely more common than people think
and the people who have intersex
condition are basically I mean basically
you could get all
sympathy in the world for them because
it's it's like people with disability
it's it's like why would you be mean to
somebody with this actual hardware thing
you know they didn't choose it you know
and and so I think that a sensible place
would have been to start the trans thing
by starting with that that's an
undeniable hardware as she said why
didn't it why did it jump over into sex
among other things and why did it get to
this place where it immediately started
saying the big bearded man is with a
penis is a woman if he says he is
because because and this is absolutely
crucial because this is not about
building a coalition it is about using
an identity group as a battering ram to
do something else and this is really key
so all right so let's talk about that
something else for a second so just in
the last couple days you may have seen
this at the LGBTQ forum that the
Democratic presidential candidates did
here in the States
they asked Joe Biden about prisons and
Biden said it should be up to the
prisoner to decide what gender they are
not up to the prison now of course this
isn't I mean this is a truly insane
thought the idea that a man could just
walk in you know be brought to the
prison and say no no I want to go to the
women's prison I identify him enough
everyone knows this is bananas it's a
little interesting to me that Biden who
I don't think buys this stuff just keeps
waiting into it because he thinks that's
his his pass or his path to victory or
something but what what do you think
what do you think he or the Democrats
really think they're trying to
accomplish with that when you do
something that's so obviously something
like that men can just pick to go to the
women's prison it's so obviously counter
to any sort of sane thinking it doesn't
seem like on its face that it's gonna
help you win well no but it stops you
being beaten up that day by the small
but very vocal group of people who
decide every 24 hours what we're meant
to think now I mean I mean we weren't
that one amazed me in some ways and
was totally predictable I mean we had
this Rao in the UK and people said when
when some people said hang on is this a
good idea like for instance what about
rapists they say oh my god that's it's
like transphobic you know like
unbelievably unlikely thing we had a
case I mentioned it in the book only a
couple of years ago where a male
prisoner identifying as a woman raped
women in a women's prison in Britain
says we didn't make this up because we
wanted to be specially transphobic that
Rea it's a real risk and it happened and
there are real female victims of it like
what do you make of that
why do you weigh that up against you
know as I say what we meant to say today
and I just just quickly I think the
fascinating thing about this is this
requires a reasonable adults to say look
I'm not making anyone like some kind of
you know I'm not trying to whip up a mob
against trans people not rent it as we
always told I'm not trying to make trans
people kill themselves or other people
kill them I'm saying I don't think it's
wise to for instance allow a male to
self-identify but the reason we're stuck
in this is because we have prevented
ourselves from having the conversation
what I lay out in the trans chapter of
this book is so far as I know the the
most careful attempt to delineate what
is reasonable and what is totally
unreasonable in the trans debate because
because we've got to be able to think
about this and speak about it and the
fact that Biden and others get stuck in
this mess is because we have forbidden
ourselves from talking about this or
thinking about this issue among many
others so are you amazed
despite writing this book how quickly
you can get the so-called feminists of
one group to betray their beliefs in the
name of some other group so a couple
times you've sort of referenced the
confusion now amongst feminists because
now you're gonna have feminists arguing
that men should be allowed in women's
prisons you're gonna feminists arguing
that biological men should be allowed to
outrace and wrestle women which we see
this happening now all the time so
they're betraying the very cause which
which they self-proclaim to be their
cause and yet and they do it like that
yeah because a little bit of bullying
goes a very long way and we live in a
society where a small number of people
can bully the most powerful people in
the world and it's an amazing thing to
watch this and I just I blame people for
being bullied on these things you know
there is a particular problem which is
that on all of these issues there is a
problem for people who work in the sort
of world where they have a hierarchy
above them that is vulnerable and most
hierarchies at the moment in business in
government and elsewhere are very
vulnerable actually and we live in this
very strange position where a relatively
small number of us are actually able to
tell the truth as we see it we may be
wrong we may try stuff out and be proved
to be wrong but a relatively small
number of us actually are in a position
it seems and it's only because we don't
have to answer to and we'd have no one
above us you know there's no one if I
misspeak on one of these issues or
something you know I can't be fired by
anyone I just you know look like an
idiot if I get it wrong and so but but
that's fine but but most people aren't
in that position and the extent to which
as I say bad ideas have been pumped
through the system you know at a record
speed it is because too few people
actually have said hang on a minute
hang on a minute I'm not going with that
I'm not going with the big bearded man
with a penis going into the women's
prison are you afraid that if we don't
get more of those voices brave worse or
just stupid or whatever it is the the
few people that will talk about these
things if we don't get more of these
voices and more and more people sort of
bow to this loud minority that
ultimately what will happen is that when
this thing gets to the breaking point
that good people are suddenly going to
become homophobic good people will
suddenly be transphobic good people will
be misogynist and race
in the mote it would be the most twisted
awful thing but given the choice between
not being able to say what they know is
biologically true or suddenly being kind
of bigoted against the people that are
forcing it down their throats that
decent people are going to break that
way well you see I think this is
happening on each of the issues you know
I say some of it some of this in the gay
chapter because I suppose like Hank it's
the one card I've got in this if you
want to play that stupid game that they
they want to make us play but you know I
mean I say there that there are days
sometimes I read the press where I
wonder how a heterosexual feels reading
it I give a couple of days in the New
York Times just to give an example where
not where the business pages are all
about being gay and the culture pages
you know and and there's a version of
this I do in the chapter on tech which
is varied arranging which is the same
thing the tech companies are doing sped
up the same thing The Times and others
are doing which is basically using gay
forcing gay down straight people's
throats to say suck it up love it take
it you bigot and I just I love this tone
and it's just there all the time people
using gays to punish bigots particularly
in America it's assumed by the press and
the Google companies and others that
this is to do with that this is
basically you're punishing Trump
supporters you're making everything more
gay to punish the bigots we have it in
Britain with this sort of presumption
that after the brexit vote was sort of
the public need to have stuff they need
to be exposed as the bigots they are so
when you search for gay couples on
google images you get gay couples but if
you search for straight couples you get
force-fed gay couples I mean try it out
anyone watch it you'll see exactly what
I mean why does this happen it's because
they're saying basically screw you for
being so bigoted as to look up straight
couples now you get this in a really
ugly way with the race one and the race
chapter in this book uh it's it's so
difficult this is such perilous terrain
but let me just quickly dive into a bit
yeah please see I I think that this
weaponization of people's races at the
moment is just the most terrifying one
of all I grew up
in London in the 1980s and London was
already a pretty diverse very diverse
actually but I had people of every skin
color at my primary school and so on I I
never thought about it at all I never
thought it was interesting or important
you know I it just wasn't a thing now
that isn't to say that there wasn't
racism in the past it certainly was but
my experience is basically that we were
we were sort of in a colorblind place
what he's getting to a colorblind place
and then this extraordinary thing
happens again the bad ideas start and
American campuses and then seep outwards
but you get things like you know there's
queer studies Black Studies and so on
and these things are basically things to
celebrate people who might have been
passed over and to sort of is a sense
but idea in some it's a sort of correct
people being overlooked as they have
been in the past if they're from some
B's minority group particular racial
minorities now I think that that there's
an insidious thing that happens with the
disc the creation of so-called whiteness
studies whiteness studies is the first
study of these studies that aims to
problematize a group that is that black
study celebrates black writers and
others queer study celebrates so-called
queer writers and others but whiteness
studies and that is an attempt to
problematize whiteness and what you get
if you try to problematize whiteness is
that you have to problematize white
people now I think and I demonstrate
this within a reference to the pop
culture world and my others I think this
is meant but at the point of which we
should have sought to become colorblind
suddenly everything has become race
obsessed color obsessed and I think we
can already see in the time in the last
few years we can see one of the results
of that which is that I think that and I
mean I'm just putting it out there and I
put it in the race chapter at the end I
think that one of the things that's
that's come from this and this is a
really awkward discussion but I've
wondered in the last few years why did I
Q start to crop up in the discussion
subterranean at first and then sort of
creeping out you know this as I know
this you know we've got pretty good
pretty good feelers and tentacles for I
think I think I can save both of us for
the sort of where the debate is at
and I just noticed it audience members
for instance that events I was doing and
then summarize you know the pub
afterwards aside like and asked about IQ
IQ isn't my thing I'm not like you
specialist but I started to become aware
of what was happening and what I think
is happening is because some white
people or a lot of white people have
been given this you know whiteness is a
problem thing and they hear these terms
like gammon being used and they hear
they hear it they hear it they hear
basically the rights movement the racial
issue moving past equal and going for a
bit to better like gay and like other
that they they see that happening and
some white people I think are reaching
around for a tool to hit back with and
some people have chosen to use IQ to
bash back and this we see here the root
of a really ugly ugly thing and and
isn't the the most crazy part of that
and you lay this out of the book
actually that when when decent people
like Sam Harris for example tried to
wade into this discussion as he did with
charles murray of the bell curve the way
that he then gets attacked as if he's
you know it's a race realist or
something like that but even even the
very minor touch of just trying to talk
about something that's gonna get you
pillared - sure sure I mean but I mean
this is this is the most dangerous one
and for America in particular you know I
mean I you know one of the extraordinary
things in recent years has been the way
in which you know everyone talks about
the globalized world and globalization
all that but actually one of the
consequences of this that this sort of
not that noted is that we all become
vulnerable to the worst bits of each
other's culture you know the American
racial problem is pretty unique to
America actually I mean this isn't to
say we haven't had our own racial
problems in in the UK and we haven't had
our own racism in the UK but but but but
the way which the American racial issue
has sort of spread globally and the
ideas of it have spread globally I give
the example in the race chapter in my
book of the way in which some of this
has sort of come to Britain and Europe
in recent years of
specific issues of the of the American
experience and and as I say one of them
one of them that's that that's just very
very worrying to us it should be
worrying is the way in which
colorblindness has been passed over as
an aspiration and has actually been
turned into a problem and I cite some of
the academics who started that aweful
who actually said colorblindness is a
problem and you get to this place you
get to this place that Robyn D'Angelo a
professor of whiteness studies in
America got to recently but she's
actually saying in a public talk that
it's a problem when people look at
people for their personality for their
character basically and pass over or try
to ignore the color of their skin and
just go wow it took you half a century
to totally erase the legacy of Martin
Luther King and run straight against it
so when you hear these people speak and
when you're doing research for a book
like this what what is it that they want
at the end you know after they've
posited all their theories and let's
pretend they're all right and we
shouldn't look at the individual and we
shouldn't you know judge people based on
their thoughts but we should but judge
them based you know it's the complete
reverse of what they're you know
supposed to be doing what is it that
they want at the end what what should
happen to the five year old white child
who has done nothing wrong who forget is
not guilty for his parents sins or his
grandparents ends and maybe maybe all
his ancestors had no sins related to
anything racial or anything like that I
mean what is it that they actually want
do you think do you think they even
think about it in that trick lens or
it's just about the immediate conquest
of the day I'm very loath generate
attribute motives but I think that the
political or the the political push is
very very strong at this point I think
that this is the thing of each of these
groups being used as a battering ram as
I diagnose it a battering ram to bring
something down what is the something the
something is what we always hear about
the white patriarchal Cicero normative
capitalist etc etcetera now some people
doing this are doing this I expose them
in
book for completely basically Marxist
reasons and I go into the Marxist sub
structure of some of this because you
just can't ignore it
it's spelt out by some of the scholars
and writers that I cite they spell it
out the working class led us down they
didn't provide the revolution we need to
go to interest groups identity groups to
try to produce the revolution this time
that is undoubtedly happening it's been
one of the things that's been happening
for the last ten years in particular and
that's why we get this fundamental
hitting at the root of the society to
present that societies like ours is
uniquely racist compared to what
compared to where as particularly
transphobic compared to where and and so
on and so on and now you see I think
that this this has to be understood that
the the ambition of the attempt has to
be understood in order for it to be
undone done because the I mean you know
one we haven't touched on yet but it is
absolutely central to all of this is
this whole discussion of privilege you
see I think the privilege game and I lay
this out in the book is an unwinnable
game it cannot be done the whole
implicit bias stuff you know which again
it's in company after company you know
and you would have thought that if
you're gonna roll something out as being
the ideal for every society on earth
you'd have thought eat of stress tested
it a bit first yeah oh no no not at all
no again how do you play this privileged
game how do you win it actually is it
the case that you can find out exactly
where you are in this hierarchy and and
work out where somebody is and of course
not I share in the book how you can't do
this it's a dementing game and it's not
it's not just you you can't play you
can't win it so why are we being invited
to spend our lives looking at the world
through this horrible zero-sum reductive
lens why are we being invited to do it I
think we are being invited to do it by
people who no it cannot be
not only those people some people
actually think trickier as I say younger
people who are being wooed into this
actually think that there is value and
worth in this but a lot of people
inviting us to do this because they know
it cannot be one and it will among other
things demoralize us and it will it is a
highly demoralizing game well and it's
also so bizarrely disconnected from
personal reality so you Chelsea Handler
the comedian for example her new Netflix
special is all her apologising for her
white privilege but if she really wanted
to apologize for her white privilege she
might have given that slot to a black
woman say Monique or some other black
comic but she doesn't really mean it you
don't really mean it get out of the way
she means it like I'm gonna get mine and
I'm gonna make myself feel bad for it so
that you think I'm really really great
examining it one of the one of the
things that that really has to be called
out in this is that the problem is some
very smart people as she clearly is have
worked out how to behave in this era a
lot of other people including the some
smart people just haven't had the same
opportunities Mars um are gonna keep
crashing and burning against this so the
clip I give the example a very em we
should spend some time on the
heterosexuals because they're no
minority they're still out there god
bless them and they need our support
Dave then you know there's an example I
give in the book of how a certain type
of male works out how to behave in the
post me to world an example I give is a
example of the cuttlefish which you may
be familiar with the cuttlefish has a an
ability to the male cuttlefish because
the ratio of men to women is not in the
male's favor the male cuttlefish can
find a way to make itself more and make
itself smaller to approximate the look
of the slightly smaller female
cuttlefish to sneak in under the male
consort cuttlefish and so it doesn't
look like it's so threatening get under
the female cuttlefish
then have its wicked cuttlefish way with
her now when I was told this first I
just said oh my god I mean I have seen
this I know this I know this male
heterosexual couple fish behavior now as
I say this is like the Chelsea Handler
thing the clever ones work out maneuvers
in this area and I know a lot of I've
observed a lot of clever smart often
well-to-do heterosexual males in this
era learning that this is the thing and
behaving in this particular way I give
an example in the book the moment I
heard but they said oh my gosh a
colleague of mine at the spectator in
London was at the women's March protests
after the Trump inauguration and
described to me being at a party sort of
I can't quite do the American accent but
the British accent would have been like
load of guys sort of jocks and you know
as I sent over the girls it all been on
the March you're like yo yo yo like it
was so totally onside yo yo yo like [ __ ]
Trump they would start not bad Marine
Abed they they were doing this and all
the time you know and then the last girl
in this particular group leaves the
circle and one of the guys okay all
those nudges he's made oh my god man I
can't believe how much [ __ ] there is in
this room
okay they had made themselves like
diminutive feminized men in order
actually to sneak in and get the women
this was pure cuttlefish cuttlefish now
the point is is that some people like
the Chelsea Handler case know that the
safest way through this era intha their
bid is to play the privileged game to
play the whiteness problematizing game
and to do all that I'm not interested in
Chelsea Handler's psychosis okay I'm not
interested in how is your what I am
interested in and really really worried
about is how young men and women are
going to get through this era if they
are all made to play this game because
they can't play this game and they need
to be helped out for from this game they
need to be assisted out of it because
this has to stop we cannot have this era
go on where people's skin color and
sexuality and gender is constantly made
into this horrible zero-sum game where
women are used against men men against
women different races we can't have it
and as I say but people who play the
game like Chelsea Handler at the top
have an unbelievable advantage they are
playing the game they've worked the game
out they've nixed the game it's in their
favor for the time being but millions of
other lives are going to be wrecked in
trying to understand it so which way
then do you think we should play the
rules on this because I think this is
now suddenly the debate you know we've
seen Justin Trudeau caught in brown face
or blackface or whatever you want to
call it this is the same guy who would
gladly call you know any of his
political opponents racists or sexist or
homophobic and we'd of course we know if
it was the conservative leader that had
been caught like this Trudeau would have
said he has to step down and the rest of
it do you think then that the
clear-thinking people out there who
don't want to play by these rules in the
first place
have to apply their rules to them or is
there or are you supposed to let it
slide and and be better knowing that
they would use a
on you to take you out for the very same
thing what do you think tactically is
the best way well I think tactically
actually it's important to use moments
like the Trudeau one to make a very
important point you see I have a chapter
one of the interlude chapters in this
book is about forgiveness I can't get
people to focus on this issue but we
have to focus on it see one of the
problems I cite a really remarkable
essay by Hannah Arendt from the 50s on
this she writes in the fifties a great
problem of of us in the world as human
beings was always the problem of action
in the world because we could never undo
an action once it happened and we had no
way of seeing what the consequence of an
action would be just like we can't
actually tell the consequence of all our
words how did we or how did we get
around this great horror only by one
mechanism which was to have a mechanism
of forgiveness because everything else
in the world cannot beyond everything
cannot be undone everything and this
makes us terrified unless we have a
mechanism and the mechanism is
forgiveness now here's the thing in the
modern age and this is why I don't like
all this talk of young people being
snowflakes and so on say [ __ ] no I think
it's a completely reasonable completely
reasonable reaction to a world in which
action has never been more perilous
because in the social media world
everything else anything at any point
can destroy you
utterly okay it's not surprising it's
not surprising that people become
incredibly fragile about action in the
world but at the same time that action
in the world has never been more more
dangerous we spend no time in our
societies thinking about the only
mechanism that ever got us out
forgiveness so here's we can try it on
Justin Trudeau and it's worth doing the
point with Trudeau should not be to play
the game back say haha
we know how Yuna behaved if it had
turned out the Stephen Harper did
blackface all the time or or if you know
Donald Trump turned out to like Justin
Trudeau I mean who couldn't remember how
many times he he'd been caught on camera
again and wasn't sure I mean it turns
out maybe they're a load of times he
just you know blacked up for himself
seemed to be his thing right but but the
thing is not to do that and say haha
we'll play it back to you but to say
okay let's stop the game for a moment
let's just stop this game for a moment
okay we don't think that you are a big
old racist Justin because you had this
sort of fancy dress fetish thing for
some time and living is embarrassing
okay
we all make embarrassing mistakes in our
lives
prime ministers and plebeians alike okay
we're all gonna make mistakes so let's
use this as some kind of learning moment
and let's specifically say we will treat
you with the kind of benefit of the
doubt that we would like to see you try
to do to other people in the future so
we're not gonna pretend you're a big
horrible racist but don't you start
doing that in future again why don't we
use this as such a moment because I
think we've talked about this before to
a great extend everything in the public
sphere in the last decade has reduced to
how can I expose my opponent as a big
old homophobic transphobic racist anti
female and this has to stop because
we're stopping ourselves from thinking
we're stopping ourselves from thinking I
mean I give the example in the women
chapter here go what could we have been
thinking about how about motherhood
how about motherhood whilst we were
playing these weaponizing games about
which Hollywood actress was paid less
millions and she could have been whilst
we were boring ourselves with that why
did we as Camille Paglia said why did we
bypass motherhood as a serious
discussion because I think we all know
the extent to which women in our society
are unhappy with the fact that that
question remains pretty badly addressed
by feminism uh why an increasing number
of girls were basically lied to by the
society said yeah you can't gonna have
it have a baby at any stage basically
and didn't didn't explain the different
biological clocks of men and women or
said you know we're so fine you can just
freeze your eggs that'll do it and so
and then end up at a particular point in
their 30s where they rise hell hell this
this actually I was told something that
wasn't true but why don't we address
questions like that instead of being
poured onto these dementing wastes of
time so one of the things I really want
to do is to say to people not just let's
understand what we're being invited to
and say no but identify what we should
be doing instead because we should be
doing absolutely anything instead of
this all right well that that is a
beautiful closing statement I will ask
you one more question to add on to that
though which is the same question that I
asked you last time you were in studio
and you've sort of referenced this
already but it seems to me that there is
a bravery deficit all across the world
right now which is why there's such a
small amount of people willing to talk
about these things when I asked you last
time what makes you Douglas Murray what
makes you willing to do this and you
said something to the effect of that you
might find out if you stick your toe in
the pool that the water is not that cold
you did that in a better British accent
than I can you just can you just expand
on that a little bit because I do think
we're getting to a breaking point with
the average person the person that's
watching this or listening to this right
now they're ready to break in the right
direction all of the things that you've
laid out here for an hour there on
bored but still at the most personal
level they're still afraid what could
you give them you know I am I mean
thinking about this a lot
I say an introduction to this book when
I was researching this book I heard
offenders in the British Army and he
introduced me to a metaphor that was on
my mind what would become on my mind
there's a system that the British and
American military have is called a great
Viper in Britain and it's a an anti
landmine device in you you put it on the
back of a truck you fire this big
missile and it has a long cord that fire
that unravels behind it and the cord is
filled with explosive and it goes all
the way across the minefield and once
it's across the minefield it detonates
now I realize this is what I wanted to
do with this book this is my great Viper
the aim of it the point is it cannot
clear the entire minefield but it can
make it safer for people to cross a my
aim of with thinking out loud on all of
the hardest issues of our time and the
ugliest and the most perilous and the
most dangerous issues of our time is
firstly that it's absolutely fascinating
it's just fat I mean it's tough I talk
about in this book I think nobody has
talked about before about why for
instance there is some always going to
be some residual issues about
homosexuality and and race and being a
woman and more and the reason I do this
is because it's fascinating but also I
want other people I want I want people
not to be destroyed for trying to think
about things that actually are things we
should be thinking about and you know in
recent years like you I've just been I
mean so moved by the fact that you know
I thought you the thing used to say was
like well young people aren't interested
young people aren't intimate I just have
found in recent years I'm sure it's the
same with you I think we've talked about
this in private
young people people in their teens and
twenties are turning out of things and
they are just great
you know they are just great they they
what they are so sharp and I find them
everywhere in the world you know I
travel all the time and just some few
weeks guy was in Reykjavik and somebody
on the street comes over says hey you're
Douglas Murray I know you from a firm
YouTube and this this this guy in
Reykjavik was exactly a
point in the conversation you're at in
LA and I'm at in London and loads of
other people run this he's got the
ability to actually get us forward on
issues and what has struck me and just
really moves me is that in recent years
I have I've been asking people in
audiences of events I've been speaking
at and at events I've been in the
audience of why they're turning out
because the audience says I experienced
I'm sure this is I know this is case
with you and events you do in the ones
that Jordan has done some of the events
I've done with Jordan and with Sam and
others we don't all agree on stuff you
know and and there are other people you
know I could add to this who we agree
with even less but but the point is is I
started to say to people little while
ago why why are you here you know and I
I base you basically get two answers the
first is I'm fed up of setting him you
know sitting on my own
watching YouTube videos you know great
as that is I'm not dissing it and but
but but they say basically I wanted I
want to meet other people not who agree
with me not to agree with me but who are
thinking about the same thing and so
there's a turnout of audience for some
of us for some of us that's basically
rooted in that but here's the other
thing the second thing they say and I
just
it's incredibly moving is that they say
always a version of this which is I want
I want to be near people or in the same
room as people who are telling the truth
and
and I want to be near them to see them
to witness it to be in the same room
because I would like to tell the truth
in my own life I would like to be able
to be a truthful person and
so much in our culture just tells them
lie engage yourself in little lies and
that's why I mind about the little lies
I don't think the little lies are just
little lies I don't think the why can't
you pretend there's such a thing as
gender queer and non-binary and do they
them I don't think it is just a little
lie I think we're being we're being
primed for bigger lives down the road
and all of history suggests that if you
demoralize people with little lies you
can make them have to agree to huge lies
and you see here's the thing as I say is
it it's a terrible thing for our
culture's that we should end up in this
position where people starting off in
their lives want need to be near anyone
who seems to be telling the truth as
they see it and I'm not being self
aggrandizing on that God knows I don't
have all the answers any more than
anybody else does and I mean just
there's a heck of a lot we've got to do
and an awful lot of thinking that needs
to be done but I find this such a moving
thing that that the young people in
their teens and twenties they want to
tell the truth to their colleagues their
friends their their contemporaries to
their boyfriend the girlfriend they want
they want to live in truth they want to
be exploring truth and they can and they
just that's one of the great things that
I just think we can do in our time
people like us and they're just millions
of people who many of whom don't have a
voice yet but who will have one who will
have a voice and who I think just we
have such an opportunity now
to get off the lies and to get on to
what we should actually be doing with
our lives Douglas you are one of the
clearest cleanest most brutally honest
thinkers that I know and I'm proud to
call you a friend and what I'm gonna do
is put my fake glasses on one more time
even though I don't need to read the
title of the book the madness of crowds
the the link is right down below if
you're watching on YouTube and I thank
you my friend and I hope that next time
we will do this in a room together and
then we'll break some bread after sound
good
it sounds great as long as we can raise
the glass as well well at least one but
knowing us just right the bread and you
guys can follow Douglas on Twitter at
Douglas Camry thanks Douglas been a
great pleasure if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell